[Musique]
Jonathan Trudeau Michel Coget allait
Gaston gay bonsoir bonsoir
jeudi on a maintenant une date il y a
certains ministres je dis certains
est-ce qu'il y en a qu'un seul ou
certains je vais vous entendre là-dessus
qui savent qu'elle poste ses occuperont
jeudi après la constitution du nouveau
Conseil des ministres Jonathan tour de
table d'abord sur est-ce qu'il rebrasse
profondément
le Conseil actuel est-ce que à tous les
postes clés sauf la santé on s'attend
des changements ou l'équipe économique
reste devrait rester en place qu'en
pensez-vous
je pense qu'il y aura une certaine
stabilité donc beaucoup de changements
en termes de nombres mais reste que les
postes-clés pour l'essentiel on va voir
les mêmes joueurs au même endroit on dit
sans cesse que Christian Dubé le seul
qui est reconduit mais je pense qu'on
puisse douter que Pierre Fitz Gabin va
demeurer au développement économique
même chose pour Éric Girard au final
peut-être un petit point d'interrogation
sur son Annabelle voudra-t-on lui donner
davantage d'exposition et mettre
quelqu'un d'autre au trésor mais on voit
que ces joueurs là principaux devraient
demeurer en place mais pour le reste du
matin quand même à passablement le
changement parce qu'il faut se rappeler
que dans les quatre dernières années
François Legault de façon j'ai envie de
dire assez exceptionnel de pas mener de
remaniement ministériel majeur donc
plusieurs ministres qui étaient en place
depuis le début du mandat c'est très
long 4 ans pour un ministre de
l'intérieur d'une même machine et un
confort qui s'installe d'un côté de
l'autre donc assurément qu'il y a
plusieurs ministres qui vont irriter de
nouveau défi jeudi prochain on passe à
l'éducation notamment on passe mais
d'ailleurs l'éducation il y a pense que
battu Michel sait Auger un record de
Claude Ryan on disait qu'elle est pas
faire trois semaines puis il a duré le
ministre l'éducation il faut lui donner
ça Michel C
la durée non sa difficulté par exemple
mais aujourd'hui à prendre son monsieur
Roberge de place le haut de la pyramide
finale santé bureau budget de l'état
économique c'est important au monsieur
le groupe évidemment ça ça va pas bouger
mais au niveau au deuxième niveau là
éducation dans toutes sortes de
ministères sécurité publique transport
etc ça ça peut bouger et c'est pour ça
que je fasse ça va être un assez gros
remaniement parce qu'il va y avoir des
changements il y a des gens qui ont pas
performé d'une part il y a des des
vedettes qui ont été recrutés alors il
faut faire la balance en tout ça et il y
a aussi
4 ministères à un moment donné
on peut donner affaires canadien à
quelqu'un aussi alors je pense que pour
ça on va avoir donc assez de changements
jeudi prochain mais pas en haut de la
pyramide
je m'attends un conseil des ministres un
peu plus volumineux que le précédent 26
ministres je serai pas étonné qu'on
passe à 28 ou 30 on ira pas au 32 de
Bernard
Landry psychologique au Québec mais
certainement qu'avec le nombre de
députés qu'il a de bonne qualité aussi
François Legault il est capable d'avoir
un conseil
des mines plus imposant ce matin ce qui
est au moins autant de femmes que
d'hommes et pourquoi pas peut-être plus
de femmes que d'hommes s'il veut marquer
l'histoire François Legault il a les
effectifs pour avoir davantage de femmes
que d'hommes à son conseil des ministres
plusieurs recrutent de qualité chez les
femmes députés de la CAQ donc ça aussi
je pense qu'il pourrait marquer le coup
s'il le souhaite et pour ne pas répéter
ce que Jonathan et Michel ont dit
Jonathan aussi à part dans les
ministères déjà pré-identifiés parce
qu'il y a d'un mouvement de personnel
assez important ça a bien c'était bien
de garder certains ministres pendant
longtemps parce que je pense par exemple
à l'éducation c'est des portes
tournantes au moment donné on avait un
ministre par année c'est bien d'avoir
une stabilité imprimée une direction
mais faut aussi une fois de temps en
temps montrer à la machine qu'on est
capable de coup de barre et là je pense
qu'il y a un nouveau mandat ça s'impose
ce coup de barre là le gros coup de
barre qui avait eu c'était à la santé en
fait quand il a mis monsieur Dubé puis
là il a il y avait un feu à éteindre
mais sinon il y a pas eu de si gros coup
de barre Jonathan sur la difficulté
j'entendais depuis plusieurs jours les
gens dire s'épouvantables on pense à
Robert Bourassa il y a eu ce casse-tête
là etc oui mais en même temps
oui il y a des vedettes à placer mais
c'est un cancer qui est possible
épouvantable que ça pour monsieur
Legault il a de bonne carte devant lui
Jonathan là
il faut mettre les bons joints au bon
endroit il reste que c'est quand même
une espèce de de quadrature du cercle
que monsieur Legault va faire parce que
quand on regarde sur papier le nombre de
bons joueurs le nombre de bonnes
candidatures je suis d'accord avec Alex
lorsqu'on parle par exemple des
candidatures féminines c'est fort fort
impressionnant le de faire la liste des
candidatures féminines qui en tout cas
tout le moins sur papier pourraient
avoir accès au Conseil des ministres
donc il faut mettre les bons joueurs aux
bons endroits aussi essayer de ménager
les susceptibilités avec parler
peut-être d'un conseil des ministres
gonflé peut-être deux sièges maximum
moi-même à 30 je commencerai à trouver
ça beaucoup mais il y a pas beaucoup de
latitude donc il va créer du
mécontentement et c'est pour ça que
moi je suis David que il pourrait y
avoir une opposition de l'intérieur du
caucus parce qu'on parle même depuis
avant l'élection lorsqu'on parlait des
perspectives de victoires éclatantes on
disait mais d'où viendra l'opposition il
y a les médias qui seront assurément sur
le regard dont on parlait de des mères
des villes qui se sont unis plus que
jamais on disait ce que l'opposition
prévenir de là attention là ça pourrait
venir aussi de l'intérieur parce que
plus vous avez du des mécontents plus il
y a des gens qui vont regarder leur
futur collègues autour de la thème du
Conseil des ministres avec un regard
assez voire très critique et qui
pourraient un peu ruer dans les
braqueurs si jamais l'aventure et plus
difficile et il voudra évidemment il
doit être représentatif des régions
Montréal Québec les vies il y en a deux
on aime Biron est pas très loin de
Monsieur Drainville à Montréal il y a
une nouvelle venue Michel C mais il doit
il doit envoyer le signal cette main
tendue qu'il a qu'il a expliqué au
lendemain de sa victoire il doit la
concrétiser pour Montréal aussi
oui il y a que deux
députés l'une est déjà ministres ça
devrait rester l'autre et quelqu'un qui
a quand même été au comité exécutif de
Ville de Montréal d'accord
de grandes qualités donc je pense que de
toute façon ce serait pas trop d'avoir
deux ministres sur l'île de Montréal
alors je pense que ça c'est presque un
acquis cela dit il y aura pas à faire
trop de d'émotions skins ce qui fait mal
à la ministre c'est pas tant de changer
de ministère alors qu'il y avait
beaucoup ça ou de se retrouver dans un
ministère moins important c'est le
Conseil des ministres ça je suis pas sûr
qu'il va faire beaucoup des des gens qui
vont carrément le Conseil des ministres
il y a quand même des positions qui
peuvent être intéressantes présidents de
la chambre etc donc
là-dessus ça va être les déçus de ceux
qui se voyaient au Conseil des ministres
de cette génération aussi qui a été élu
à cette élections qui se voyait déjà
qu'il y a des déceptions ça va plus être
vers ces gens-là que
des gens qui sont déjà dans le candidat
Conseil des ministres parce que les
vieux routiers allaient qui a des
manières comme dit Michel de trouver des
postes imaginatifs
l'imagination la créativité plus un
mandat avance qu'on est dans un deuxième
mandat plus il faut en être capable de
cette créativité là donc oui il y a des
manières de déplacer des ministres de
leur signifier aussi qui nous ont pas
performer à la hauteur des attentes mais
ça va rester des choix quand même
douloureux mais à tout prendre il va
prendre ses choix douloureux là plutôt
que d'avoir dans les mains des cartes
perdantes alors et ça peut donner ça
peut mettre la pression un peu sur les
ministres aussi vous avez un poste les
gens pour vous remplacer on va être
surveillance donc ça peut être
intéressant aussi de passer ce message
là très bien jeudi donc on sera là en
émission spéciale 13h je crois là c'est
en début d'après-midi toujours
intéressant puis il y a des on les voit
défiler puis il y a des discours un peu
bon
partie libérale du Québec madame
anglaise c'était écrit dans le ciel il
va avoir ce matin il y a eu un premier
papier avec des sources qui anonymes qui
disait bon on n'est pas content des
vieux libéraux entre guillemets Jonathan
est-ce que c'est le début Michel avait
utilisé je voulais je la donne tout de
suite Michel va être expression mais
vous aviez utilisé le supplice la goutte
là est-ce que c'est ça qui commence pour
Madame anglais qui va prendre la mesure
de l'ampleur de la défaite au cours des
prochaines semaines et que beaucoup de
libéraux en cachette vont dire ça prend
un autre chef
le supplice de la goutte d'eau mais en
même temps je suis pas prêt à dire que
l'issue est inévitable au moment où on
se parle mais assurément il y a de la
grogne vous faites référence sur au
papier de La Presse Canadienne ce matin
moi la semaine dernière dans une
chronique à la radio je parlais
effectivement d'une heure pas de compte
allemand d'une grogne sévère au sein des
militants du parti belge du Québec c'est
sûr que si on regarde des candidats
d'effets des anciens députés qui ont
fait un peu si on veut l'objet de la
politique la terre brûlée de Dominique
englade c'est pas difficile de trouver
du mécontentement mais moi ce qui m'a
frappé c'est de voir que dans dans
l'estables et schmintes au niveau des
militants des fameuses vieilles mains
libérales il y a des gens qui sont
carrément enragés le système ou une
personne qui m'a dit si elle ne comprend
pas le message nous on va s'assurer de
la mettre dehors lorsqu'il y aura le le
vote le vote de confiance donc c'est
cette grogne là elle est pas
nécessairement l'intérieur du caucus
actuel c'est beaucoup les gens qui
qu'elle choisit que le désigner qui ont
été élu mais c'est vraiment dans la base
militante du parti viral du Québec et ça
je pense que la partie loin d'être
gagnée pour pour Madame anglan non parce
que Michel c'est dans le caucus c'est
des gens qui ont été élu c'est des gens
qui qui savaient dans quelle galère ils
allaient et puis ils sont bons ils sont
élus ça change pas mal de choses c'est
tous les autres
qui vont dire pardon
les petits coquilles de toute façon le
problème c'est les autres effectivement
et et vous savez d'abord ça doit suffise
le problème c'est que elle a subit la
pire des fêtes de l'histoire de son
parti il y a un seul siège en dehors de
la région de Montréal la région de
Québec tous ces gazinés au 5e rang mais
tout ça il y a pas un chef dans
n'importe quelle partie du survivraient
à ça sans problème alors avant avoir des
problèmes c'est clair est-ce que son lit
de chute va y passer c'est possible mais
c'est à la hauteur de la défaite qu'ils
ont subi et en plus je veux dire il y a
il semble y avoir des des problèmes
personnels entre madame anglaise et
beaucoup de monde qui se sent pas
écouter qui sentent pas que elle
connecte avec des gens qui sont
importants donc à un moment donné il y a
de la grogne la seule chose qui était un
peu surprenante c'est que ça arrive du
jour après l'élection c'est tout ouais
c'est comme un dieu retour à la réalité
là
on est disons que dans le réchauffement
d'un match qui va durer trois périodes
vous le dirai comme ça la première
période c'est lorsque les sources
anonymes ancien députés militants
présidents d'association aux anciens
candidats vont donner leur nom on va
passer de l'anonymat à je veux que
Dominique Anglade parte et on met un nom
dans le journal où on va à la télé où on
va la radio et on le dit la deuxième
étape ça va être le caucus c'est la
dernière rempart qu'on Dominique Anglade
c'est ce que le caucus va suivre est-ce
que des gens dans le caucus qui vont
décider que peut-être finalement à
l'approche du vote de confiance c'est
pas la personne qu'on devrait avoir au
parti et ensuite pour que tout ça se
mette en branle ça va prendre un ou une
remplaçante potentielle c'est bien de
mettre un chef dehors encore faut-il
être confiant qu'on a quelqu'un qui va
faire un travail meilleur que celle qui
était là alors tout ça prend de la du
temps à se mettre en place est-ce que
Dominique Anglade est capable de
contrecarrer cette mécanique là en cours
de route ou est-ce qu'elle va
s'accélérer à un point ou au moment
donné elle n'aura plus le on ne le sait
pas je vais essayer d'accord avec
Jonathan elle est toujours en poste
c'est pas facile mettre un chef dehors
mais en même temps le premier
grenouillage la période de réchauffement
est sur le terrain mais c'était ma
prochaine question justement vous dites
encore faudrait-il que quelqu'un qui
fasse mieux devant la caque devant
monsieur Legault qui a réussi à tirer
des gens à une équipe économique qu'on
connaît qui est devenu par la force des
choses le parti de l'économie en tout
cas dans l'esprit de la majorité des
Québécois qui aurait fait mieux qu'elle
Jonathan c'est un peu ça la question là
difficile de répondre à cette question
là effectivement mais en même temps
c'est elle qui tenait les reines du
parti puis on a souvent parlé d'une
certaine conjoncture bon d'un
gouvernement qui qui l'a eu plutôt
facile je parle en termes de capacité à
occuper l'espace médiatique parce que ça
a pas été évident le mandat avec la
pandémie mais est-ce que c'est eux qui
occupé tout l'espace madame anglaise qui
a pas été en mesure de faire une course
au leadership ça va ça avorter donc elle
arrivait avec peu d'éléments favorables
en place mais en même temps on a eu beau
dans la dans la campagne électorale
blanc mille l'organisation dire que
Madame anglaise elle personnellement
elle faisait une bonne campagne était
dynamique de lancer pas la serviette
mais ce que je plusieurs on notait
autant les observateurs que des gens à
l'interne que des anciennes du parti
c'est que après deux ans là c'était son
équipe qui était en place c'était
l'organisation qui est le même avait mis
en place des orientations qu'elle avait
contribué à déterminer des problèmes
d'identité du parti belge du Québec le
fait qu'on sache pas trop où là
Jacqueline là je vais partir du Québec
mais l'EMP de devenir candle on la
sentait donc difficile de dire qui
aurait fait mieux parce qu'on s'entend
que les candidats ne font pas
nécessairement la file et ça pourrait
être d'ailleurs un problème pour pour la
suite le qui veut reprendre ce fonds de
commerce un peu abîmé au moment où on se
parle mais j'ai l'impression que pour
des militants qui sont en rogne l'idée
de pas avoir nécessairement
d'alternative pour certains que ce soit
suffisant pour les empêcher d'aller de
l'avant d'après moi ils vont se dire de
nombreux un coup de pied dans dans la
canisse comme on dit et on verra ce qui
va se passer ensuite ouais Michel c'est
Alex là-dessus sur sur c'est une crise
existentielle profonde le parti c'est
plus très bien qu'il est il y a plus ce
combat qui les définissait plus
facilement fédéralisme donc on se
cherche
Michel c'est les prochains mois vont
être difficiles c'est une évidence les
prochains mois ils vont être difficiles
parce que
c'est pas rien perdre son identité ils
sont plus la partie du Canada puis ça
être la partie du Canada puis du pouvait
référendum pour gagner un élection
finissant
là c'est plus là alors il faut se
retrouver à fond de commerce il faut se
retrouver un chef le cocher c'est une
très grosse commande puis on l'a vu
vraiment de réclamation c'est quand même
pas pour rien on avait fini par dénicher
qu'un disant qu'il y avait l'air d'avoir
la main derrière le dos en train de se
la faire top pendant tout le temps qui a
été qui a été là pour ouvrir le
Drummondville puis finalement
c'est pas facile donc il y a toutes
sortes de toutes sortes de chantier pour
la partie libérale du Québec
actuellement elle est conclusion
ouais on avait effectivement tirer très
fort sur le bras d'Alexandre cuisson
pour qu'il se présente puis même là ça
va pas été très concluant
il faudra voir si on est capable d'abord
de trouver un chef parce que c'est un
chef qui insuffle la nouvelle
orientation un parti on peut pas faire
l'inverse il faut que le chef lui est le
goût de d'avoir certaines valeurs de
mettre l'avance certaines idées de faut
d'abord trouver un chef si on souhaite
la remplacer Dominique Anglade avant de
se dire bon voici ou qu'est-ce qu'on va
proposer maintenant qui est disponible
on entendait non est-ce que Pierre
Moreau serait disponible est-ce qu'elle
est serait disponible est-ce qu'il y a
des gens qui seraient intéressés à dire
juste partie là faudra qu'il y ait des
gens si on souhaite la remplacer face ce
travail là qu'on trouve quelqu'un ou une
ou des quelqu'un parce que ça peut être
une vraie course qui a un intérêt à
relever ce parti-là mais c'est une
reconstruction comme au hacker ça va
prendre du temps bon ça faut être
patient ce qu'on disait la soirée
électorale c'est quand on touche le fond
à qui on a le droit à un premier choix
au moins il me reste politique c'est
plus compliqué merci comme toi très
bientôt salut
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI